cet otage par renault il nous écoute
depuis le début vous n'êtes pas beaucoup
intervenus jusqu'à maintenant avait
peut-être que vous je pouvais en servir
et si je vous l'avais dit je l'avais dit
ben vous vous occupez beaucoup de votre
fille morgane vous non lolita de lolita
ah bon parce que tu te remets pas donner
notre voie c'est une expression manouche
qui signifie amoureuse très bien je
vends le club vient de l'apprendre
beaucoup saluent le plus possible j'ai
serré et ça doit pas être évident parce
que vous vous baladez beaucoup en france
non ben quand je pars en tournée j'ai
fait le ménage et quelques quelques week
end à paris alors trouvez vous mais est
ce que est ce que bono se sent
responsable de sa fille quand même comme
un jour étant bien sûr qu'à l'âge est là
aujourd'hui votre figurine à 5 ans et 4
mois je l'emmène à l'école tous les
matins à 8h vous êtes récupère nous non
je suis un père normal france devraient
tous les papas et maric détenus et
d'être d'être maladroit et je ne pense
pas que ma méthode d'éducation soit soit
révolutionnaire ou ou rétrograde en
février au feeling en fait moi ce que
j'ai beaucoup aimé c'est la chanson de
renaud qui s'appelait morgane de toi
justement je trouve que cette chanson
était très belle et qu'elle disait
simplement que vont les hommes et leurs
enfants et c'était tellement bien dit
c'est tellement beau et vous avez envie
d'avoir d'autres enfants renou bain au
départ j'en vois les six parce que ma
famille on était six frères et soeurs on
dit que c'est un petit peu une tribu
chez vous un un peu oui
et puis on s'était c'était bien c'était
sympa une bonne ambiance et
finalement j'ai peut-être m'arrêter à
nous et pourquoi ça quand tu iras le
second c'est un fait j'aimerais
l'adopter et ma femme même rien faire a
regoûté aux joies de la maternité est
déjà là il ya un peu conflit c'est vrai
qu'il ya brillé c'est le cas ils souvent
contraire on a souvent des femmes qui
disent j'ai déjà eu un enfant ça pas
toujours évident et puis j'en vois bien
à un autre mais à condition de l'adopter
là c'est une situation qu'on te croyais
que beaucoup de femmes qui maintenant ce
désir la maternité je sais pas ça dépend
moi je sais voile alors moi je sais kahn
a beaucoup et je crois même que c'est un
point important et il y en a qui ont un
plus grand désir de maternité que ce
qu'elles ont réellement y est la plupart
des femmes aimeraient avoir un peu plus
d'enfants qu'elles n'ont réellement
et ça c'est essentiel mais moi
j'aimerais revenir au sujet
d'aujourd'hui parce que vraiment j'y
tiens énormément quand on se dit que
dans cette société
un mariage sur deux dans la région
parisienne va aboutir à un divorce
bon et si on se contente de dire oh là
là c'est terrible c'est terrible et
quand ça n'occupe pas bon bah on va
aller à une catastrophe si au contraire
on se rend compte que c'est devenu
normal pratiquement normal que de
niveaux créés et que bon il faut faire
avec et être bon et en faire eux mêmes
une force le construire la société
autour de ce qu'elle a de très solides
c'est cela que j'aimerais essayer de
faire avancer de les connecter un
extrait de la chanson de renaud qui
s'appelle en cloque justement c'était le
moment où sa femme était enceinte de la
petite lolita
vous êtes d'accord pour de la faire
écouter
vous l'écoutez les knie ailleurs renault
est d'accord et là a mis sur mur au
dessus du berceau une photo d'arthur
rimbaud et ses cheveux en brosse
elle trouve qu'il est beau
en lâchant du gosse bravo déjà les
petits ans
sur papier peint je trouvais ça étrange
ge qui rien elles me font marrer ses
idées loufoques puisqu'elle est en
cloque
alors que vouliez vous dire renault
avait bousillé dit on va écouter un
extrait je voudrais dire quelque chose
après aston soupe en chansons alors là
c'est vrai des enfants des rues à qui on
demande de choisir etc c'est horrible
pour eux de choisir entre le père et la
mère le problème c'est que c'est pas
souvent c'est jamais les enfants qui
souhaitent enfin c'est pas souvent les
enfants qui choisissent ni même les
parents en cas de divorce c'est le plus
souvent la justice qui choisit qui
décide que ça sera la mère et je sais
qu'une association des pères de deux
divorcés qui unit pour avoir la garde
des enfants et ça me paraissait
important dans la signaler cette
association
oui ce que je crois que la justice dans
95% des cas confie la garde de l'enfant
à la mère est ce qu ils pas forcément
qui devrait pas être systématique sous
prétexte que c'est vrai je crois c'est
vrai c'est vrai on va écouter la réponse
de monsieur rosé avec tt juge des
enfants et puis un petit mot une madame
du foie avancé séparer alors essayez de
la réponse à renault c'est un tout petit
peu moins c'est 80% des cas mais je
crois que le problème n'est pas là comme
le dirait même du foie comment sortir de
ce droit de garde
comment permettre que les deux parents
restent parents quand ils se séparent et
comme d'une manière générale comment
permettre à deux parents d'être parents
qu'ils soient où qu'ils soient pas
mariés c'est ça le vrai débat comment
permettre l'exercice conjoint l'autorité
de nantes l'avait dit qu'est ce que vous
voulez dire non je voudrais dire que on
ne doit jamais désespérer de l'évolution
des mentalités et que la loi presque
toujours suit les mentalités donc ce qui
est important c'est que tout cas tous
les français tous des françaises qui se
disent dans flûte on est devant un
divorce est difficile c'est pas commun
etc
c'est dit il ya possibilité de le vivre
bien il ya possibilité de transformer
cette situation qui inquiète mauvaise
pour les enfants en ce moment une
situation qui est probablement une
situation de chance à condition que les
parents se sentent tous les deux
responsables sept enfants quoi qu'il
arrive qui se dispute au qui ne fait pas
qu'y salon qui s'aiment pas ça c'est
vraiment important mais si on y arrive
on peut gagner
merci madame ni fois merci d'être venu
antenne 2010 ça passe vite à ces cartes
blanches a impressionné c'est pénible
impression qui lui de commencer
c'est parce que vous êtes un excellent
merci renaud d'avoir participé à cette
antenne 2010 on vous retrouve ce soir
sur antenne 2 à 20h35 avec guy bedos qui
va fêter sa plus belle histoire d'humour
avec le public c'est ça ouais bah
j'espère que ça se passera bien
au revoir